suite on part à la chasse aux fausses
informations c'est l'heure d'un fou
intox
info intox ce soir avec julie shoot au
buzzer du liban soir antoine l'on sera
tous aujourd'hui direction l'ukraine sur
les traces de celui qu'on appelle le
fantôme de kiev julie alors qui se cache
derrière ce monde plein mystère il faut
bien le dire alors le fantôme de kiev
est apparu pour la première fois parmi
les premières fois en tout cas dans un
tweet de l'ancien président ukrainien
petro porochenko c'était le 25 février
dernier donc on était vraiment au tout
début de la guerre en ukraine était de
l'invasion russe en ukraine en était
même seulement le deuxième jour
petro porochenko représente un
mystérieux pilote qui a déjà abattu six
avions russes à lui tout seul un
super-héros anonymes qui terrifient
l'ennemi et qui fait la fierté des
écrits des ukrainiens avec des
défenseurs aussi puissant dit petro
porochenko l'ukraine va gagner à coup
sûr de quoi motiver les troupes la
légende était née légende était née
ensuite ce héros anonymes julie il
apparut sur d'autres comptes officiels
ukrainien et oui le 27 février à peine
deux jours plus tard le compte twitter
un vous allez devoir du du gouvernement
ukrainien vante aussi les prouesses de
se justifier dr le fantôme de kiev est
décrit comme un as de l'aviation qui
domine le ciel de la capitale et qui est
devenu le cauchemar des aviateurs russe
un message qui a accompagné d'un montage
vidéo et on apprendra d'ailleurs un peu
plus tard par nos confrères de reuters
que ces images ont parfois été tirées
pour certaines d'un jeu vidéo et le même
jour la page facebook des services de
sécurité ukrainiens publie elle aussi
une éloge au fantôme de kiev qualifié d'
ange des batailles celle est un rien que
ça qui a déjà frappé 10 avions russes et
plus récemment c'était le 11 mars la
page facebook des forces armées
ukrainiennes post est elle aussi cette
photo présentée comme celle du fantôme
de kiev en fait pendant des semaines ce
spectre 1 à rodez un peu sur les réseaux
sociaux d'été un peu partout les
ukrainiens que ce sont mêmes
aussi un des anonymes ukrainien emparés
du phénomène pour acclamer leurs héros
ans à coups de t-shirts de dessins et
même de chanson écrite pour lui rendre
hommage on remarque à chaque fois julie
que ce présumé super-héros bail reste
anonyme en oui sauf que vendredi
plusieurs médias dont le times de le
journal le times britannique
pensez avoir identifié un ce célèbre
phantom de kiev pour eux il s'agirait du
major ces pannes tard à bâle qu'à un
pilote d'élite de 29 ans mort au combat
le 13 mars alors le major tard à bâle
cas existent bien et il est bien mort au
combat le 13 mars sauf que attendait
j'essaye de voilà il s'agit de lui donc
le le tweet du ministère de la défense
du cri n'a confirme bien sa mort et le
pilote a même reçu le titre de héros de
l'ukraine à titre posthume sauf qu'il ne
s'agit pas du tout du pilote qui aurait
abattu 40 avions russes à lui tout seul
comme le dit la légende puisque tout
simplement le fantôme de kiev n'existe
pas et n'a jamais existé ça veut dire
que les autorités ukrainiennes juillet
on avoue avoir elle-même tout avantage
alors pas vraiment c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué que ça le bien sûr les
forces d'ukrainiens l'armée de l'air et
craignait n'a reconnu qu'il n'existait
pas il est donc en réponse injustement
l'article du times qui révélait
l'identité de cet homme et l'armée de
l'air en fait compte du conte comment
fait part publié un message sur sa page
facebook disant que stéphane tard à bâle
cas n'était pas le fantôme de kiev et
qu'ils n'avaient pas avant tu as battu
40 avions russes à lui tout seul mais
surtout dans ce tweet l'armée
ukrainienne dit je cite les informations
sur la mort du fantôme sont incorrectes
le fantôme de kiev est vivant il incarne
l'esprit collectif des pilotes hautement
qualifiés de la brigade d'aviation
tactique en fait ce que veut dire
l'armée ukrainienne c'est que ce fantôme
kiev ce n'est pas une personne un à
propre langue parlée il incarnerait
l'esprit y en des pilotes de tous les
pilotes de cette de cette brigade en
fait ce serait une représentation
collective en fait un symbole pour
représenter donc tous ces pilotes de
cette brigade
d'aviation ne s'agit pas donc d'un être
humain en chair et en os petite
pirouette donc et d'ailleurs ce n'est
pas l'unique fois julie ou le camp
ukrainien fenêtres des légendes à des
fins de propagande il faut le dire et
non il ya eu déjà plusieurs les gens
meurent mais d'un qui ont la peau dure
il a eu déjà plusieurs exemples on a vu
fleurir sur internet par exemple des
messages avec avec cette photo celle
d'une femme présentée comme une beauté
ukrainienne qui aurait abattues 50 de
chars l'ukrainien sauf que nos confrères
de reuters ont analysé la photo et
verdict c'est celle d'une chirurgienne
du service de santé de l'armée
ukrainienne du service santé donc
militaire aucune preuve et donc même peu
probable qu'elle ait abattu 50 de chars
russes à elle toute seule puisque cette
femme est plus coutumières du bistouri
un finalement que du lance roquettes
merci beaucoup julie chouteau pour à cet
éclairage donc sur le ce soi-disant
fantôme de kiev donc c'était info ou
intox paris direct s'arrête pour
l'instant il revient dans quelques
minutes reste avec nous sur france 24